Father and
mother,
no matter how disgraceful I become, you still treat me the same That's what scares me
the most
That's why I don't love you I hate
you
I wanted
you to
give up on this I wanted
you to give up But it's easy to give up Take
Subaru or make it in time
I got angry at my affectionate father What did you say?
Where is your head?
You think you're going to be hated by me,
but the way you do it is to refuse to go to school,
or if you want me to abandon you, do it more actively
Your wife is your son's crooked nature I can slap him back in if you want, but your
brain looks like it's been broken to the point it didn't need to and got back on its feet